hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to until done now I'm
gonna have more regular episodes of this
starting today there's gonna be one a
day until the game gets done I know I've
been delayed but other things got in the
way with the Jimmy Kimmel stuff and the
live stream a whole bunch of things got
in the way but now we're back on track
so this is a new Butterfly Sam needed to
be rescued by Mike I'm guessing that it
wouldn't have needed to be rescued by
Mike if I was a bit less stupid about
that
so anyway Ashley stabbed the psycho who
turns out to be oh wait was there more
to that the psycho gave Ashley a black
eye well I mean tit for tat I guess it's
okay Ashley followed Chris Ashley failed
to see who was in the workshop maybe
that's good I have no idea Chris and
Ashley found dummy when Sam's clothes
okay I know I didn't want to split up
Chris didn't shoot Ashley Chris didn't
shoot himself either because it was
filled with blanks okay so now we're
back and there is one thing that I
wanted to remember there's one more
thing that I wanted to go to before I
got here there was one of the totems
that was very explicit on what was going
on here not that one not that one I
think it was like them nope maybe not
maybe maybe that one
now I thought oh there was another thing
over here because there was another with
that now now that I'm looking at it
doesn't quite look like I don't know
what I'm getting at here but hang on
okay all right that's fine that's
definitely not Emily
that's what I was thinking when I was
thinking about this game earlier I was
wondering if that wait maybe then no
that was definitely not Emily okay so
now that I'm here I got to find a way
out of the tunnels and unfortunately my
relationship status with Matt is like
super 100% but unfortunately he did he
like super-dead
yeah now working Oh lookie some
important doodads up on the balconies
why don't I just climb up there and risk
being eviscerated by the monster maybe
it was like a choice based thing maybe
because emily has the flare gun maybe
she can use the flare gun if she ever
gets attacked but I don't know I don't
even know if she still has it she might
have lost it a long time ago after the
fall I can't imagine where she would
have stuffed it that it would have been
secure enough to survive that fall all
right anyway cool so why is this a clue
obviously there are people working here
on this mine obviously the family of
these people okay I remember there being
a flame thrower a man from the beginning
of the game are you saying that that
might be the same flame through a man as
before maybe he's just trying to scare
away the monsters and he's actually a
cool dude I'm gonna go with that
because in the beginning of the game he
seemed to be able to he seemed to be
reaching for the twins which is
generally a cool thing to do see now you
see
if my blood yeah that's just bad luck
why is it goopy I don't like the sounds
of Sloopy goop it was a trap all along
what oh okay
why don't ya bestest shout as loud as
possible
huh yeah I'm sure you'd be fine
comparatively alright skull skull skull
skull skull skull good more skulls more
decorations love what you've done with
the place you horrible creature from how
me wonders is me yeah Matt's Matt's not
here he wonders if maybe I should cause
less ruckus
Oh am I about to cause more ruckus here
I go a ruckus thing okay that was some
ruckus stronger than I thought she was
this is going swimmingly well but that's
another Tim Tim is that a totem no
that's a miner said wait wait you didn't
do the clue duty do the clue daddy come
on give me the thing give me the thing
I'm saying you didn't do this at all
right fine I guess not good enough for a
clue maybe I should stay out a little
longer so I can be stabbed hello hi let
me grasp it with my weird fingers oh you
look like a happy family I wonder how
you all died sir
dearest Billy Billy
impossible i rated in my no denotes
alright
dearest billy hurry home safely from
your loving wife and daughter
agnese and louise so somehow I'm
guessing the miners unleashed a horrible
horrible horrible monster trapped in
these mountains and that proceeded to
eviscerate everyone around so I got to
be attentive because I gotta find these
things look it's a rosy ladder sure was
how to known that back when I was
climbing up one so I've got to find the
totems because if I don't find the
totals I'm gonna be utterly boned for
the rest of the damn game not that I
know how much left is in the game
monsters creeping in the dark they want
to say hi okay so someone's fighting the
monsters is what I'm supposed to
understand oh I thought this is a
cutscene I'm just looking at myself not
that I'm not pretty but it's just what's
his deal with something okay we're gonna
clone oh we're gonna leap cuz we can do
this gotcha I'm good at this not really
that was really close I got that I'm so
good at this I climb quickly and
efficiently because I'm so great jump to
ladder of course where you think we're
but come on jump to the ladder damn it
gotcha oh you think you're so sassy I
got you look how skilled I am kind of
disproves a lot was happening before
with all my unachievable
cuz I mean the first thing we want do do
this rusty old decrepit ladders jump on
it with all of our that was weird all of
our way hi hello is someone here anybody
anybody uh you know told them around
here not like Inception style I'm
talking like a real totem maybe this is
all just inception we're all in
somebody's dream Josh's fun-filled
magical
dream okay I'm not seeing anything I
would assume like the things don't glow
until I look at him but I would assume
it would be relatively not like tucked
away in the corner that I would have to
approach it from a certain angle that's
the thing I'm actually worried about but
I don't think that's gonna happen
because I'm a scanning I'm a scanning
[Music]
lover dear okay
still haven't seen the totem I mean I'm
gonna be really pissed if I actually
miss over totems because I'm actually
like looking very attentively for totems
don't fall off the bridge please please
Emily just showed your agility and let's
look where we're walking oh yeah that's
no good
technology is unreliable best to just
burn the [ __ ] down all Mountain please
should I run away from that oh no no
let's go forward let's go towards it
probably good idea
I bet he's friendly I bet it's a
friendly dude who likes cigars and burns
monsters alive
wait burns monsters alive wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute burns
monsters
that's definitely definitely Emily and
it's a lost totem doing some different
about it but I'm gonna assume that it's
I mean it's my imagination and I
shouldn't be going towards the thing Oh
fire oh is that my fire oh that's my
fire
I left my fire there that's why okay
I'll just pick up my fire I'm certain
they won't die from it hmm
okay I didn't even need to try to pick
it up well is there some time for that
glad things are working out so nicely
let me just use my engineering know-how
- oh it's a switch maybe I should I
don't know anything yes I do
I was gonna be an engineer yeah and
definitely didn't attract the attention
of every inhabitant in this cave
including the maniac with the
flamethrower who probably lives down
this way was there any other totems over
here any other totems let me wave my
wand about I cast a spell of magic
missile on the darkness all right
anybody anybody anybody and he told him
and he told him and he told him don't
have me totally let me know no totem
okay no totem all right I mean would it
be a cliche already to say that I don't
I've got a bad feeling about this
because I certainly have a bad feeling
about this very bad feeling why am i
walking away from the elevator and
towards all the dirty decrepit stuff oh
there we go told him perfect exactly
what I was looking for hi Otto
Oh Oh is this it the first danger totem
I've gotten oh no I've gotten a danger
totem before was it oh it was red i
thought it was like purple or something
okay so there wasn't really anything
that I could have done about that one
but see huh
okay so this is like don't go walking
near the arm when I get to some weird
prison and I think that's Mike or watch
out for a quick time event or else my
guts are gonna be eviscerated out of my
ears
all right so paying attention to that
thank you for the heads up finally got a
damn totem I mean I don't think all of
them have been that easy to find that's
literally out in the open right there
hey look - Chloe's oh oh oh all right
what's that what am I looking at is it a
pebble coin Rock do I need to do
something about that I don't like that
sound
I don't like many of these why am I
going away from the elevator I probably
shouldn't be but here I go I guess I'm
alrighty then here we go headfirst into
danger is this creeping up on me so I'm
gonna happen something's gonna happen
Oh cutscene
oh this is where they fell I don't think
you can't have Emma Emma Emma Mme ME ME
ME mo Emma me know you're really good at
climbing and jumping according to my
skills but I don't think you can climb
that it's in this where they fell down
like the two sisters this is where they
fell down right why can't I look at this
can I look at this there we go edge ger
edge how do you know that's what that
said could say anger edge oh oh oh she
has a butterfly too to see when are you
getting yours Beth oh she's got a
butterfly too - okay okay now I get it
now I get it
oops sorry didn't mean to press that
sorry okay hello here's where they foul
it is okay yeah she fell down she didn't
do too good okay so you actually found
Hanna's glasses are there any other
information about that Hanna's broken
glasses found near a sheer drop into the
mind she must have fallen near here yeah
no doubt and then someone took the
bodies for some strange reason what's
over here can I get that what is that
what is it can I please thank you
oh this doesn't seem good let me just
Pat that a little bit I need to get an
idea what I'm gonna be moving here let
me judge the weight a little bit feel
pretty robust
so did Hannah survive cuz I'm willing to
bet Beth didn't survive that fall
whoever's back landed on the rock is the
one that did not survive at least that's
what I'm thinking
hang on let me fly and everything here
I'm just trying to explore thoroughly
move that's what I thought i theorize it
now done not flunking it anymore now I'm
actually living it okay so there's
nothing else over here mmm poor Beth oh
it's so sad though there's no way she's
still alive down here this is to be no
way possible then someone's angry at
something over there see water and fire
was that symbolic is something am I
supposed to gather some strange meaning
from it I don't know what do we get over
here
anything over any other secret hidden
doodads oh this is the other side of the
wall this is where I was looking at a
thing hello thing I was looking at what
the hell are you oh it's a lot
oh it's Hannah's necklace I think
Hannah's locket oh there we go
Wow
that's so sad and there's still monsters
are creeping around everywhere Hana's
tarnis locket with a portrait of the
washington family inside it can't have
fallen here someone must have moved it
further into the mine you damn right
okay so that was important because it
distinctly showed me that through the
fence
therefore it wanted me to find that
really badly alright what else do we got
hello let me just try to figure that
YMCA thing down alright fine whatever
remember when I was not funny same exact
time as today wasn't that great times
all right wherever so there was
something it was showing me down here I
don't know if this way I'm supposed
I'm gonna go the other way first how
about I go the other way I'm gonna I'm
gonna go the other way first I'm gonna
go the other way first I have a distinct
feeling there's not good over there okay
so is there anything over here that I
need anything over here that I need
anything over here that I need okay it
doesn't seem like it I'm gonna go say hi
to the doll or whatever it was some
weird scarecrow no that was nothing okay
I'm exploring thoroughly
the music gonna creep up again I bet it
is hello hi god you're so weird
hi there yeah let's do this as creepy as
possible I'm going back there I gotta
find out you're gonna brave it up Emily
this is important shiz yeah that's not
good
why was the cross over there and then
they headed over here and why is it
still kind of preserved I mean I guess
it's cold but I don't think it'd be cold
enough for it to keep it that well it's
been a year things don't things don't
decompose slowly they decompose real
quick yeah anywho let's keep going on
now that we got that lovely thing out of
the way hello oh this is the back way to
the elevator okay so now I'm gonna get
out of here eh okay with no worries at
all right good now that I found all this
information I can take it back to my
friends and family and survive unlike a
certain boyfriend of mine all right good
what is that up there oh that's probably
nothing all right let's just
is there anything else I'm forgetting
Hey nope nothing I'm forgetting okay
let's go hello elevator you're my best
friend let's get out of here quickly
expeditiously I hope I didn't forget
anything for some silly reason
yeah and yo whoa whoa hey whoa I think
you might have noticed the fire you're
holding there oh okay then no I'm not
gonna get back there you've got a slim
thrower okay quick times good times good
times good times any more any more
wait wait wait wait wait no okay maybe
that was a good idea it slowed him down
I wasn't even ready for it
I'm doing good I'm doing good I think
you said not on fire hide hide we gotta
hide last time I turned back what the
hell would I do if I turn back okay
weapon controller for now move mode
[Music]
oh well that didn't work it out of that
didn't work at all okay there we go
[Laughter]
right how does it feel do you enjoy
feeling terrorized humiliated I mean
panicked all those emotions that my
sisters got to feel once one year ago
only guess what they didn't get to laugh
it off no no no no no they're gone I
don't know if you noticed this Josh but
none of us are laughing oh come come
come come come why the long faces come
on it's good to get the heart racing
every now and then right and race they
did I mean every one of you just pitter
pat pitter pat I hope you appreciated my
little phantasmagorical spectacle such a
delight to play the puppet master to all
of your Pavlovian panic bodies I mean
that she was expensive and no retakes
nope nope nope only double takes oh you
should have seen your faces hook line
and sinker for every little stinker
Josh why are you doing this yeah don't
even ask this squirrely little runt
he's got no clue he's out of his [ __ ]
tree he's definitely off his meds oh
come on you guys
revenge is the best medicine you're done
he might be sick what come on you guys
are all gonna thank me when you guys
become internet sensation say what what
oh oh you better believe this little
puppy's going viral ladies and germs I
mean we got the unrequited love we got
we got blood
I don't think there's enough hard drives
in China tip to count all the fuse we're
gonna get you guys what are you talking
about you asshat
Jessica's [ __ ] dead what did you hear
me
jessica is dead we're gonna [ __ ] Maddy
ah guys guys come on seriously this is
crazy you know shut up man huh
what's it the [ __ ] hit her aah what
are you talking about Ashley you piece
of [ __ ] I got so mad you don't hit a
girl you just don't dude dude Chris bro
I'm not your bro where we going where
you guys taking me locked up whoa
what I can't do anything stupid before
we call police in the morning
I know I didn't do anything
are you serious bro god damn murderers
what you are I didn't do it Michael
please just listen to me man I did not
hurt Jessica
see wait no hang on wait whoa - scolder
de smith dismiss would completely negate
the argument that he's trying to make
scold would say he's come too far which
is probably what I'd say I don't want to
dismiss his claim but I just want to
know how much he screwed up which he did
Thomas told him are you insane like
really do you not understand what you
man I bring people together
okay I knew this story it was gonna be
more complex than it seemed suckers
can't take a joke oh did I hurt you you
just feel a little sorry man I can't
tell you how sorry I am that something
happened to Jessica but I swear I swear
wait okay
angry or skeptical skeptical means
something's like it said something feels
wrong like I don't want his anger to
blunt because I want to say that Mike is
being a little over-enthusiastic but as
far as he knows he thinks he thinks jess
is dead and he killed him like it's kind
of justified what he's doing here so to
be honest Chris has to be the voice of
reason something feels wrong joking I'm
just having a really hard time figuring
out that you would like do anything to
hurt Jess I saw
with my own eyes this this this is her
blood well it would help if you weren't
being such a creeper Josh I knew I
didn't trust you we're supposed to party
like porn stars not pies at all
oh he's just trying antagonizing now cuz
he's it might be a little unstable way
okay wait
see defensive or aggressive Chris Chris
being defensive about himself or
aggressive would probably complement
what Mike's doing now so he needs to
play on the defensive a little bit
because to be honest it's like a good
cop bad cop right here Mike's being the
aggressive one but also Chris knows
there's something else going on here
there's some more to the equation what
would have happened if I'd have chosen
to like make the Machine go left I make
I'm guessing that Josh assumed then you
never know okay so I'm assuming he needs
to be defensive here see you're the
coward yeah huh I made you believe in
the world I created and I showed you
parts of yourself you are too afraid to
visit okay you tricked us you hurt your
friends and you did it all while you hid
in the shadows you're a coward Josh
that's all you are
it makes sense
yeah sand down Josh okay it's still Ryan
right right right
okay and time up if they're just week
over Rob hi dude I need be a little
wiggle room ah what does it take to shut
you up
oh not so tight okay not so tight again
ties that's worth in God's name is he
talking about this is hard to watch and
I never imagined in my wildest dreams
that you liked me you know what that
sound is it's a sound of never kissing
Ashley you plus a stop yeah you know you
might as well let Ashley sleep with Mike
I mean at least he's got some notches in
his belt
you know you'll treat her right
you're [ __ ] pathetic Chris I'm gonna
bite his head off don't listen to him
not worth it hmm didn't even give me a
choice there Mike Mike Mike Mike Mike
Mike what what happened with Jess Mike
now the important question finally we're
getting to the meat of the issue no no I
don't
I got a problem Mike I don't remember
killing Jesse Christ I mean like I feel
like I would remember killing her you
know
to solve and she's probably got like a
really tight but shut your [ __ ] mouth
oh now who's the not calm one no Mike
don't do stupid I don't even know if
there's weight disarm disarmed Mike
disarmed Mike don't be a douche well
just next time give me a heads up all
right make sure everything's all right
Oh cause it's true you can we have a
do-over I want to do over I'm gonna hit
you in the face
everything's fine back there right yes
split up split up again split up is a
good idea split up is a great idea
all right shaft fight should I hit him
in his freaking head
all right anyway I'm gonna skip past
this so that's all for this episode
thank you everybody so much for watching
click damn Jason for what it is that
I've done in the past and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
that's how you're gonna play this game a
game baby I'm home come out and scooty
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]